presidential candidate Nikki Haley
has a suggestion
for a way to improve our political order
and that would be mental competency
tests for the old guys running the show
we need to have term limits in Congress
and we need to have mental competency
tests for anyone over the age of 75 and
I don't say that to be disrespectful
when you go and you look at Biden and
you and you ask him what country he was
in the week before and he can't say it
when you go and ask him how many
grandchildren he has and he doesn't know
when you go and see him falling asleep
with leaders that's concerning that is
concerning and I really like Nikki Haley
personally this is not a good idea
because we already have a mental
competency test for all of our
politicians of every age and that
competency test is called an election
and the competency test takes place at
The Ballot Box